It's one of those things like the
walking on coals to absolutely.
I've done a number of times, I'm sure,
but if you, as long as it's cold,
you know this then that Coles are
not a very good conductor of heat,
which is why you don't Cook on Friday.
She took on that bullshit. Be caught. Yes.
I'll tell you what my experience
was. I, the first time I tried it,
uh, I was with a group of
maybe 40 people and it was a,
the standard length of the
walk was about 12 feet.
It was a hot fire was mesquite
and it was in my yard in Tucson.
And the guy came in,
it was early in the days of firewalking
and he had this long four hour thing to
get people ready. Uh, I was not in
the right mental state when I did it.
And my experience was it felt fucking hot.
And,
and when it got to the end of it,
the,
it condensed down to like a number
of points that really burned.
And I had blisters the next day. And
most people that have walked that night,
it looked like they were not
in the right mental state.
But I saw a few people who
strolled across it that looked,
they were in some
interesting altered state.
So I wanted to try it again next time
I did it, I shouldn't have done it.
I was with a guy who was a real jerk
who thought himself as a, you know,
he's a self styled guru,
small group.
It was a shorter maybe eight foot cooler
bed of coals and I got significant
burns from that.
So like an annoying guru.
So it's really annoying saying no idea
what she'll still idea what he was doing.
Like this guy's a jerk off and then you're
getting annoyed so you're out of your
mindset. Right. And I burned my feet so
I said I'm not going to do this again.
And then a friend of mine was doing some
intensive workshop with Tony Robbins
and so Christ and it was
going to end the last day.
They were going to do try to set a
record for the longest firewalk done in
America. So he wanted me to come
up. So I went up there, I thought,
I'm going to watch,
I'm not going to do it.
So it was a 40 foot bed of
coals and it was a really odd,
and he had like a troupe of
African drummers and people
are dancing and drumming.
It was like midnight and people were
getting in line to walk and I said,
I'm not going to do this and I can be by
family self, you know, going up there.
And I was right there and he taps me
on the shoulder and says, you're ready.
It felt like walking
through crunchy croutons.
There was no sensation of heat.
I walked slowly.
I kind of wiggled my feet and the
things and when I got to the end of it,
I felt so high. It was like on acid.
I had energy rushes through my body.
I had nothing on my feet.
So on a much shorter cooler walk,
those coals conducted just fine.
And uh, you know, when this one,
it's a mind body thing. It's not
about the connectivity of the coal.
Tony Robbins hitting you with some
fun gazey, Kohl's. It was hot.
I mean you could barely get at the edge
of the thing. Men, the heat was amazing.
You know the Tony Robbins one,
it's what's really interesting is
recently they've developed this issue with
people trying to take selfies while
they're walking across the coals burning
their feet.
It's become a significant issue because
it didn't happen till like within the
last one.
I've never heard of that.
I think that would get you right
out of the proper state. Yeah,
there was a big article about it that's
pretty big article about these people
really their feet up a well deserved.
You really think that you have the ability
to mitigate the amount of effect that
fire and Cole hot coals. I don't have
any proof of, this is my intuition.
I think what happens if your mind
is out of the way you can take,
you can absorb energy and let it flow
through your body rather than getting
blocked in the tissues
where it causes damage.
And I've seen this in other situations
as well and I think the problem is
ordinarily our mind is in the way of
that and does not let the body freely do
that.
And I think that applies to things
like getting hit really hard, uh,
heat getting hit really hard.
How, what do you mean? Getting,
letting someone hit you as hard as they
can with something that would cause
damage and that doesn't, oh, that's crazy.
No it's not. I've experienced it. Yeah,
I'm sure you have.
But are there a real scientific studies
that show that nobody's studied it?
I'd love to study it. Nobody's
studied fire walking, you know,
the usual scientific explanation.
It's like we probably shouldn't talk about
this until they do do studies because
it seems so simple to do these studies
and I'm not fine if for a second.
I think if I hit somebody they're going
to, it's kind of fucking hurt right.
If you get Deontay wilder to punch you.
I don't give a fuck how much Tony Robbins
talks to you in common experience. Uh,
drunks involved in car accidents don't
get injured. Okay, but do you know why?
Because they're totally relaxed.
Yes,
but that has nothing to do with some
altered state of consciousness is not
allowing the injury to actually matter.
Mind is out of the way and
their body is totally relaxed.
So it does the tension of falling.
You hurt yourself because you're defending
yourself. You're right. Right. You,
your body is better off
giving in to the whole,
I'm saying it's the same thing
with the fire, but it can't be,
that's a different thing
cause you're not tense.
It's on this surface of your skin, which
is causing the he, no, I think you're,
you're tense in your nervous system,
which is not letting,
not able to absorb that
thermal energy and Brown.
We're going to do some studies on a
burn. You, I'm going to burn you anytime.
We'll try it. Buy It. It just,
I think there's certainly,
you can mitigate the sensation of pain.
I don't believe that you can do anything
about the actual physiological change
to a hot piece of metal interacting
with the tissue of your skin.
I just think they'll like the steak
does not know it's being cooked.
It's just getting cooked. You're going to
get cooked. You are a meat. I just don't,
I don't buy that. I'll show you
some of these studies on hypnosis.
There's doctors right now going,
yes. You tell him Joe Rogan,
this is nonsense. Well, I believe
that hypnosis, I do believe that,
but I absolutely believe you can achieve
different states of mind where you feel
things differently.
Your, your concentration,
your relaxation is in a different state.
Your mind set is in a different state.
I do not believe that you can change
the physiological nature of your body's
ability to absorb punishment
like a punch kick.